♪
>> I WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW HERE
THE COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE WE
DO NOT MANDATE THE VACCINE.
AS LONG AS I'M YOUR SHERIFF, WE
WILL NEVER MANDATE THE VACCINE.
WE BELIEVE THAT YOUR HEALTH
CHOICES ARE YOURS AND YOURS
ALONE.
SO WHETHER YOU GET THE VACCINE
OR DON'T GET THE VACCINE THAT'S
YOUR PRIVATE INFORMATION.
HERE, WE BELIEVE IN AMERICA AND
FREEDOM.
AINSLEY: THAT IS PINAL COUNTY
ARIZONA SHERIFF MARK LAMB SAY
NOTHING VACCINE MANDATES ARE
COMING TO HIS DEPARTMENT IN A
VIDEO THAT'S GONE VIRAL.
SHERIFF LAMB JOINS US NOW WITH
MORE ON HIS MESSAGE ON PERSONAL
FREEDOM AND THE RESPONSE THAT HE
IS GETTING.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SHERIFF.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
AINSLEY: THANKS FOR BEING ON
WITH US.
YOU GOT SO MANY VIEWS, MORE THAN
65,000 AT OUR LAST CHECK.
WERE YOU SURPRISED?
>> NO, WE KNEW IT WOULD GO
VIRAL.
IT'S A HOT TOPIC IN THIS
COUNTRY.
FRANKLY I DID IT BECAUSE I'M
TIRED OF SEEING WEAK LEADERSHIP
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND WEAK
LEADERSHIP AS IT RELATES TO
PROTECTING THEIR EMPLOYEES'
RIGHTS.
WE WANTED TO DO SOMETHING THAT
LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT HERE WE
DON'T TOLERATE THAT.
AINSLEY: WELL, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS PUSHING
BUSINESSES TO MANDATE THIS WHY
ARE YOU AGAINST IT?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S PEOPLE'S
PERSONAL CHOICE, YOU KNOW,
HEALTH CHOICES HAVE ALWAYS BEEN.
YOU KNOW, LAST YEAR, IT WAS LIKE
PULLING TEETH TO GET A LIST OF
ANYBODY THAT HAD COVID, SO THAT
WHEN MY DEPUTIES RESPONDED TO
THEIR HOUSES, WE KNEW WHO THEY
WERE.
NOW THESE SAME PEOPLE ARE MORE
THAN WILLING TO GIVE UP ALL OF
YOUR PUBLIC HEALTH PRIVACY FOR
THE SAKE OF SECURITY AND I'M NOT
OKAY WITH THAT I DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD CHANGE.
AINSLEY: HAVE YOU GOTTEN A LOT
OF SUPPORT?
>> OH, I HAVE GOTTEN A TON OF
SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW, YOU GET YOUR PUSHBACK,
TOO.
SOME NEWS OUTLET CALLED ME A
REBEL.
I DON'T KNOW, I GUESS THAT'S A
GOOD THING.
AINSLEY: ALSO IN ARIZONA, WE
REPORTED ON THIS YESTERDAY,
BORDER PATROL AGENTS CAUGHT
THESE MIGRANTS THAT WERE
ATTEMPTING TO ENTER THE UNITED
STATES IN THIS FAKE BORDER
PATROL VEHICLE.
AND THE DRIVER WAS WEARING A
FAKE CBP UNIFORM.
THERE IS A PICTURE OF THE CAR
THAT THEY WERE DRIVING.
LOOKS VERY REAL TO MOST OF US.
BUT I GUESS IF YOU ARE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT YOU RECOGNIZE IT'S
NOT REAL.
WHAT OTHER DETAILS DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, THEY DO THIS ALL THE
TIME.
LOOK, THIS IS A BILLION, BILLION
DOLLARS INDUSTRY OF BRINGING
DRUGS AND HUMANS INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY WILL EXHAUST EVERY RESOURCE
TO TRY TO BRING THEM IN HERE
UNDETECTED.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THEY
HAVE USED, THEY HAVE PAINTED A
TRUCK TO LOOK LIKE A BORDER
PATROL TRUCK.
THIS IS WHY AS SHERIFFS WE ARE
STANDING TOGETHER BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT DOING
IT WE ARE STANDING TOGETHER
PROTECT AMERICA NOW.
TO PROTECT AMERICA FROM BAD
THINGS, BAD POLICIES, PROTECT
THE PEOPLE'S CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS.
AND HOPEFULLY YOUR LISTENERS
WILL CHECK IT OUT PROTECT
AMERICA NOW.COM AND COME SUPPORT
US.
AINSLEY: SHERIFF LAMB, THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING ON WITH US.
>> THANK YOU, AINSLEY, I
APPRECIATE I